cette vidéo est sponsorisée par Nord VPN
et c'est bientôt la saison des vacances
avez-vous pensé à prendre votre
VPN alors en fait moi j'ai perdu mon
emploi cette année à cause de la crise
économique du coup bah je peux pas trop
me permettre de partir en vacances cette
année c'est pour ça il faudrait que
j'économist pour payer
l'opération je peux répondre je peux
répond oui oui et vous monsieur du coup
ah ouais moi j'ai pensé évidemment à
prendre mon
VPN
sinon nor VPN vous permet de continuer à
regarder plateformes françaises depuis
l'étranger ou vos films et séries
exclusives sur les plateformes
étrangères comme Disney plus ou Netflix
depuis n'importe quel endroit du monde
interviewons au hasard une autre
personne dans la rue Monsieur monsieur
qu'est-ce que vous pensez de Nord VPN ah
ben je pense qu'ils sont je pense qu'ils
sont formidables toujours disponibles
c'est clairement le meilleur VPN du
marché exactement nor VPN c'est un outil
de cybersécurité tout en un qui évolue
constamment avec N VPN vous pourrez
chiffrer vos données vous assurant ainsi
anonymat et confidentialité mais c'est
aussi la protection antimmenace ainsi
que la surveillance du Dark web qui vous
alerte en cas de fuite de vos données
mais n VPN quen disent les experts oui
et bien regardez je verse ce liquide
bleu dans cette serviette et voilà tout
est absorbé aucune perte oui et et
VPN bénéficier de 4 mois d'abonnement
supplémentair gratuit sur un abonnement
de 2 ans offre uniquement valable par le
lien en
[Musique]
description salut tout le monde alors
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui on on
va on va attendre que ça
s'arrêtein Seb tu arrives bientôt parce
que bon on a un épisode à tourner on est
grave en retard et et l'endroit est un
peu inquiétant je
[Musique]
trouve j'arrive je te vois je suis là
dans une minute à tout de suite
[Applaudissements]
bon ben voilà moi aussi je suis tombé en
panne mais je suis avec Maurice le
dépanneur et il va nous emmener j'ai
plus
d'essence bon mais c'est pas grave on va
appeler un autre dépanneur mon téléphone
a plus d'essence
on va marcher hein je connais un resto
routier à 5 minutes d'ici hein pour nous
aider
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
allez hey Jojo tu aurais pas un
téléphone fixe s'il te plaît parce que
on est tombé en panne à côté pas de
problème je chercher
ça ça c'est Jojo de J dans le nom de J
dans le sang bon petit conseil te fais
pas remarquer il y a beaucoup de G qui
cument les routes de
Bretagne regarde
làbas c'est livreurs
uber tu CIS qu'ils arrivent à survivre
avec leur salaire de merde bien sûr que
non pour ça qu'il fautrondir les fins de
mois donc trafic d'héros de Cam de ta le
cannabis ça que c'est les meilleurs et
celle-là là-bas c'est les
picouenes on peut les croiser dans toute
la Bretagne fais ga à elle sont super
dangereuses il les regarde pas dans les
yeux
sont complètement
beurré et eux là c'est
les ils sont petits mais costaud il y en
a même qui disent qu'ils les ont vu
voler
là ça c'est le mur il essaie de faire
croire que c'est une plage mais je peux
te dire que quand tu fonces pour te
baigner ça fait mal j'en sais quelque
chose
bref pas l'attention et tout je passera
bien t'inquiète pas j'attire jamais
l'attention
[Musique]
oups désolé j'ai pas fait exprès
ouais c'est pas grave ça
arrive j'ai faire une connerie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
pourquoi on n' pas pris ça nous parce
que
merde on est
où
ah voilà bon c'est quoi le jeu du jour
alors attends avant qu'on commence euh
j'ai un petit cadeau pour toi ah voilà
depuis le temps que tu voulais
ça qu'est-ce que c'est devine c'est une
voiture non c'est un f pizza non c'est
une arnaque presque c'est un f pizza
alors non c'est pas un four à pizza
allez je
l'ouvre oh c'est un four à pizza oui
mais non mais c'est parce que j'ai
utilisé le carton pour enfinf
W oh une Xbox 3 60 elle est neuve elle
est complètement neuve mais t' rappelles
tu en voulu une depuis très longtemps
c'est vrai que je voulais ça ouais je
m'en souviens ça il un jpec de
secrétaire aussi que je garde toujours
dans tous les épisodes à côté de moi
mais attends c'est pas une console
récente mais pas du tout je veux dire
elle date de 2005 elle a 20 ans l'année
prochaine 20 ans ah oui c'est carrément
rétro en fait ah ben super B il y a même
un jeu avec
[Musique]
1 2 3 4
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ride to L rétribution un jeu sorti en
2013 c'est-à-dire en toute fin de vie de
la console pour tout vous dire en fait 2
mois après la sortie de ce jeu il y
avait la Xbox one qui sortait et du coup
vous savez ce que ça veut dire ça veut
dire que le hardware était complètement
maîtrisé donc ce jeu ça va être le
bouquet final de la console un jeu
vraiment abouti le jeu commence donc par
une petite scène cinématique en moto qui
nous montre
ou là attends on joue là déjà ok donc on
a une scène où on mitraille des mecs
avec une sulfateuse c'est absolument pas
maniable d'ailleurs mais bon c'est pas
très grave on tue donc trois mecs super
facilement puis d'accord bon ben c'est
terminé j'en étais où oui oui je disais
que on joue mais qu'est-ce qui se passe
là je joue je joue pas décidez-vous tout
ça pour du QTE là qui qui sert à rien en
plus mais regardez j'ai lâché la manette
ça ne change rien ce qui se passe à
l'écran mais bref tout ça était en
réalité un genre de Flash Forward où le
jeu te dit en gros on a aucune idée de
comment commencer cette histoire ce qui
est plutôt sympa en vrai parce que ça te
donne l'occasion de laisser tomber avant
même de commencer après cette intro le
vrai jeu commence sur votre héros de son
nom Jake qui sort d'une caserne après
avoir terminé son service militaire il
retrouve son oncle Renault connard de
Mac qui l'attend dehors à gros
muscleville vous êtes rejoint par votre
petit frère Mikey qui voudrait bien de
venir un mec cool comme vous he du genre
qui rotte devant turbo en buvant de la
86 mais qui surtout voudrait bien
rejoindre ses potes pour s'amuser sauf
que votre oncle refuse parce que c'est
dangereux dehors il décide malgré tout
d'attraper une moto et de s'enfuir vous
partez alors à sa poursuite ce qui nous
permet de lancer la première phase de
conduite et la première
observation vous aussi vous allez
accueillir les gos dans tr moi non alors
clairement ce jeu m'a permis de
connaître un nouveau type de postapo que
je ne connaissais pas c'est l'apocalypse
routière qu'on appelle aussi Paris
cintamuros en latin il y a des
conttainurs au milieu de la route des
tractopelgaré n'importe où des énormes
tuyaux pour évacuer ce qui semble être
des millions de litres de merde et
clairement tout ça doit être chiant pour
les gens qui vivent ici genre pour cette
petite voiture
oui chée je su route je suis en route
vers Carrefour besoin de rien de spécial
oui et aussi on clairement dans un
univers où personne ne sait
conduire comment c'est même possible
techniquement de se retrouver comme ça
peut-être qu'il a appris à conduire
extrêmement bien juste pour être un
connard bref on rattrape notre petit
frère quoi mais pour aucune raison
particulière en arrivant dans la ville
soudainement des gros mecs musclés
débarquent et commencent à nous
embrouiller bref on décide de tracer la
route pour éviter la bagarre mais un des
méchants repère le blouson sur le dos de
notre cousin et nous demande de nous
arrêter je vous demande de vous
arrêter il s passé quoi là on s'est
téléporter e
stop
arrêtez-vous
attrapez-les les gars emparez vous
deux arrêtez
[Musique]
allez bon ben alors vraiment le jeu est
très très mal écrit mais on reviendra
dessus plus tard et c'est reparti pour
de la moto avec ce coup-ci une scène de
course
poursuite alors je veux pas juger mais
la scène de course poursuite de Final
Fantasy 7 elle est mieux et c'est même
pas le jeu principal bon après chacun
son avis mais le mien est mieux non mais
vraiment ces séquences vous ne contrôlez
rien les ennemis se gluent à vous
automatiquement dès qu'ils sont proches
et après tu as juste une touche sur
laquelle appuyer et si tu appuies pas d
on dirait que le jeu ne sait pas comment
réagir
désolé en gros dans ce jeu il y a trois
types de séquences en moto il y a la
bagarre sur les motos qu'on vient de
voir les courses poursuites vous devez
rattraper un seul ennemi et enfin aller
d'un point A à un point B ah mes
préférés
[Musique]
mais le point commun aux trois types de
passage à moto que je viens de citer
c'est que les motos n'ont même pas l'air
de rouler en fait il y a aucun principe
d'adhérence aucun dérapage il y a même
pas de système de roue avant ou de roue
arrière votre moto c'est qu'un cube qui
se déplace de gauche à droite niveau
sensation de conduite pour vous faire
comprendre on est assez proche de ces
jouets qu'on avait quand on était gosse
et pareil il y a aucun crash aussi
aucune chute les impacts n'ont aucun
effet sur votre personnage même si vous
prenez un train dans les dents à 180 km
la seule conséquence c'est un fondu au
noir salut tout le monde c'est toi
faites au moins des crashes violents ou
des CINES à la con ù tu t'éclates comme
une merde comme ça au moins même quand
tu perds c'est un peu satisfaisant bref
retour à l'histoire les ennemis nous
attrapent parce que la veste que porte
votre frère appartient à un ancien gang
rival disparu nommé les rétributions
auquel on comprend que votre oncle a
appartenu dans le passé votre frère se
fait égorger devant vous tandis que vous
vous vous faites un fondu au noir ça va
commencer à se voir hein que vous savez
pas ce que vous faites mais en fait
révélation tout ça absolument tout était
un
flashback mais comme je disais avant le
jeu est très mal
écrit en fait pour vous expliquer il y a
un flashback dans le flashback les
ennemis vous ont laissé pour mort mais
vous avez survécu mais là moi je vous
dis ça parce que nous on a revu les imag
plusieurs fois mais la première fois
qu'on l'a vu on avait vraiment rien
compris et ça va revenir plusieurs fois
le jeu va alterner régulièrement entre
les flashbacks et le présent sauf que
votre personnage a exactement la même
tête et les mêmes vêtements dans le
présent que dans le passé attends donc
ça c'était le passé ok donc ça veut dire
que ce qu'on a vu au tout début du jeu
CIT le futur
donc donc le jeu nous a il est la FA en
fait ah oui et j'ai oublié de dire un
truc aussi sur les phases de moto il y a
aussi un système de boost alors quand tu
l'utilises en fait tu vas tellement vite
que tu laisses la caméra sur place
pendant quelques
instants je je vais même pas perdre 10
secondes pour pour vous expliquer à quel
point c'est vraiment une idée de con ah
oui et aussi parfois il y a des ralentis
alors je sais pas trop ce qui les
déclenche mais
c'est mais [ __ ] mais vous savez pas ce
que c'est qu'un ralenti en fait faire un
ralenti ça veut dire que le monde est
ralenti c'est c'est pas genre la moto
qui passe en première l'ennemi arrive et
Tac fondu au noir tu as compris ouais
ouais pas de
problème ok on a besoin des noirs sur le
plateau nous voilà donc arrivés dans
l'histoire à Las Vegas la ville qui ne
dort jamais
avec tous ces gens dans les rues
quelqu'un on est donc là pour chercher
de la daupe afin de retrouver les gens
qui ont tué mon frère j'en profite au
passage dans ce niveau pour aider une
jeune femme qui se fait emmerder voilà
donc ça c'est fait et donc
[Musique]
qu'est-ce qui vient de se passer et bien
en fait quand un monsieur et une madame
s'aime beaucoup ils vont dans la chambre
et ensuite ils vont je sais ce qui vient
de se passer merci mais pourquoi ça
vient de se passer ça n'a servi à rien
dans la mission c'est la dame elle m'a
pas donné une info pour retrouver mon
frère ou quoi non non non rien je viens
de me faire siphoner les noirs et le jeu
fait comme si rien ne s'était passé in
et tout travail mérite salaire save pas
les gens
gratuitement on croise donc une serveuse
noire dans un bar qui nous donne des
infos sur l'endroit où trouver le
gangadmi mais malheureusement on perd la
trace du type qu'on poursuivait on tombe
alors sur une mécanicienne qui veut bien
nous donner l'info en échange d'un coup
de main pour récupérer son alliance on
la ramène donc jusqu'à la maison en
question on fait la mission en tabassant
quelques connards et une fois que la
mission est
effect [ __ ] mais bordel on on est dans
un film de cul ou quoi là
qu'est-ce qui se
passe non mais c'est ça l'idée du jeu on
va arroser le jardin là de toutes les
femmes qu'on croise excusez-moi est-ce
que vous pourriez sauver mon chat coissé
dans l'arbre bien sûr madame il pas de
problème et ça ne s'arrête pas là parce
que des meufs vous allez en baiser plein
dans ce jeu en fait chaque personnage
féminin que vous croisez et dans 100 %
des cas une scène de cul potentielle si
vous voulez ma théorie là-dessus c'est
qu'en fait tout ce jeu a tellement une
imagerie crypto gay avec tous ces
personnages qui font de la moto torsenu
huilé en portant des blousons en cuir en
se parlant avec des voix suaves on
dirait que le jeu il a besoin de se
rassurer en fait 100 % é
ici j'adore le vagin j'adore les Lolo
j'adore la M je je veux dire j'adore
mettre la [ __ ] dans leu
[Musique]
ça ne s'arrête jamais c'est vous sauver
la moindre femme dans une rue à côté
d'une poubelle allez on remue l'calope
non mais vraiment ce jeu c'est un champ
de mine du sexe ça peut exploser à
tout on dirait des blagues en fait on
dirait qu'il y avait un mec qui se
baladait dans les bureaux des
scénaristes quand ils étaient pas là et
qui s'amusait à rajouter des et là ilule
bref après ça
encore un flashback ou
pas j'en sais rien je vous jure
l'histoire est incpré et donc on arrive
sur le premier gros passage en tps du
jeu avec cette scène dans l'entrepôt un
passage très long d'ailleurs puisque
jusque là toute les mission durer genre
5 minutes maximum alors que celle-là
dure plus de 40 minutes et ben c'est
c'est c'est pas bien c'est pas à chier
en fait disons que c'est enfin si si
c'est à chier mais disons que c'est
c'est disons que comparer un génocide
c'est
mieux ah presque presque
par contre comparé à deux génocides là
c'est mieux pour que vous compreniez ce
que je suis en train de vivre même sans
avoir la manette en main essayez
d'imaginer que le feeling de combat
c'est un peu la même chose que GTA Vice
City qui lui est sorti en 2002 et qui
est mieux d'ailleurs on découvre aussi
dans ce passage qu'on a un mode Fury qui
apparaît un petit peu n'importe quand
avec votre personnage qui subitement va
faire cette tête constipation
occasionnelle inutile de vous confiner
dans vos toilettes ah oui et par contre
il est possible que le jeu a un léger
petit chou tiny problème d'équilibrage
sur certains ennemis
bref après ce passage dans l'entrepôt on
a donc à nouveau une scène de course
poursuite avec cette fois comme
originalité que ce n'est pas vous qui
conduisez vous vous serez à la
mitrailleuse d'ailleurs on est
visiblement dans un monde où tout
explose en dérapant si c'est des motos
quand elles dérapent elles explosent les
ennemis quand ils se gênent entre eux
ils explosent mais même quand tu tires
pas dessus et que le pilote tombe ça
explose attention chérie il y a un petit
peu de verglas là
mais clairement je comprends que
personne met de casque visiblement ça
sert à rien regardez cette scène je dire
ok alors les flics mettent des barrages
pourquoi pas mais déjà les barrages ils
sont clairement pas terribles monsieur
je maintiens que ce serait plus efficace
si on mettait les deux côte à côte non
non on veut pas ok ok alors au moins
est-ce qu'on pourrait virer le
trempelin surtout la vraie question
c'est pourquoi ça
explose on est genre un spectacle de
Disneyland je trouve ça cool que les
flics dans ce jeu sont un peu plus bêtes
que
genre des castors et nous voilà donc à
la fin du prologue on peut maintenant
personnaliser sa moto ainsi que vendre
de la drogue pour gagner de l'argent ah
qu'est-ce qu'on ferait pas pour la
justice quand même à partir de là on
entre dans un genre de hub dans lequel
on va pouvoir refaire des missions
secondaires acheter du matériel des
armes customiser sa moto dans un
magasin et aussi le meilleur truc
bloquer des passants je crois pas
j'étais dors tranquillement je marchais
et puis là il y a un titre qui se met
sur mon chemin et du coup maintenant je
suis bloqué là je surever ici du coup
retour donc à Las Vegas où on retrouve
la serveuse de tout à l'heure qui se
fait embêter par des mecs du groupe
licence 4 on la sauve et bah si
évidemment voilà allez c'était le seul
personnage fémininin à qui j'avais
adressé la parole sans lui coller une
lasagne dans le four il fallait bien
réparer l'erreur allez hop et la galette
complète sur le billard
génial et je tiens à souligner au
passage que le bar était pas fermé hein
sinon à propos de la grenadine que j'ai
commandé et vous vous demandez sûrement
si on peut aller plus loin dans la
beaufferie je sais pas ce qui est le
truc le plus honteux du jeu c'est c'est
ça ou le gameplay mission suivante et là
alors accrochez-vous parce que là ça
devient stratosphérique on est donc
toujours à la recherche pour rappel du
GAN qui a tué notre cousin on les a
retrouvé enfermés dans une ferme mais
problème il y a un grillage électrifié
impossible de rentrer on se retourne et
là la caméra nous montre un gros camion
citerne le jeu nous demande donc d'aller
vers le camion citerne dans la station
service juste à côté un autre être
humain tu es
làz des dialogues avant les combats bref
donc à ce momentl tu te dis bon ben je
vais prendre le camion citerne et foncé
dans la clôture électrique pour passer à
travers mais non à la place on va donc
faire une autre course poursuite dans
laquelle on va assassiner des dizaines
de flies qui explosent spontanément par
simple contact visuel parce que le seul
truc qui n'explose pas dans ce niveau
c'est ton [ __ ] de camion citerne
rempli d'essence on finit en le
balançant sur une centrale électrique et
en faisant sauter le barrage en tuant au
passage tous les employés qui tentaient
de nous empêcher de commettre cet acte
terroriste tout ça pourquoi pour couper
le courant de la clôture électrique de
tout à l'heure quoi il y avait pas genre
plus simple et alors mon autre idée en
fait c'était de remonter dans le temps
et de tuer le mec qui a inventé
l'électricité et on rentre donc dans le
complexe des méchants en ne passant même
pas par le grillage mais par le mur en
plus la con de tes vieilles coup on
libère une meuf qui était là qu'on baise
évidemment parce queil y a clairement
rien de plus excitant que de faire la
toupie moldave à côté du cadavre de type
qu'on vient juste de buter et ah benah
d'ailleurs il y en a un qui a raté le
trou et on reprend donc la bagarre juste
après du coup quoi alors les ennemis ils
attendaient dehors sans intervenir ou
alors si on est allé tellement vite
qu'ils ont pas eu le temps
d'arriver c'était les meilleurs 5
secondes de ma vie on fuit une
moissonneuse batteuse on rentre dans une
grange où on trouve le boss celui-ci
s'enfuit on tire alors sur une bouteille
de propane
pour pourquoi non mais vraiment pourquoi
ça ça ça ne sert à rien c'est c'est
juste pour créer une fuite spectaculaire
dans une grange en feu mais qu'on a
nous-même provoqué ça ne sert à rien et
attendez je précise he parce que là il y
en a qui vont peut-être commencer à
douter mais ça n'est pas un jeu
humoristique c'est juste que votre
personnage est un attardé on s'enfuit
dans la plus grande décharge du monde
oui j'en ai pas parlé mais les décors
n'ont aucun sens excusez-moi les avions
de ligne c'est dans quel Ben et nous
voilà enfin dans le combat contre le
boss attention musique de
boss musique de
boss musique de boss non bon B tant pis
alors ben léger bruit devant sur une
pleine vide pour MP3 alors bon alors
après on peut reconnaître quelque chose
au jeu c'est que les missions sont
relativement varié par exemple la
mission suivante ça consiste à tuer des
gens sur un ring de box oui oui j'ai dit
tuer c'est c'est juste des exécution en
public il y a pas d'autres mot mais
alors attention évidemment c'était pas
lui le méchant parce qu'en fait et bien
le méchant il travaillait pour le
méchant encore plus méchant donc le
méchant encore plus méchant tue le
méchant à travers le poteau du ring ce
qui est très fort vous l'avourez et bref
à ce stadelà et bien vous avez vu tout
ce que le jeu a à vous proposer on
alterne en gros tout le long entre
baston phase en tps et moto et le jeu
prend environ une douzaine d'heur pour
tout finir quand vous le faites pour la
première fois et on voit bien que tout
ça est très mauvais et le peu qui n'est
pas très mauvais n'est clairement pas au
niveau d'un jeu de 2013 on rappelle que
la Xbox one sort 2 mois après alors on
peut expliquer une partie de ces
problèmes par le fait que RA toell
rétribution a été dans ce qu'on appelle
un développement l le jeu a été
développé par e techniqu édité par Deep
Silver un éditeur très prestigieux connu
pour plein de jeux plutôt cool et il
devait à la base être un open world dont
on peut encore voir quelques résidus
dans le jeu avec ces phases où on se
déplace sans rien faire et dans des
missions qui ressemblent à des mission
dans GTA mais en plein milieu du
développement du jeu dont la sortie
était prévue pour 2008 l'éditeur achat
complètement ces développeurs qui durent
finir le jeu de leur côté tout seul et
sans financement changement de câ donc
toutes les missions du jeu furent relié
mal par un scénario bancal et évidemment
et bien on voit le résultat et on avoue
que chez JDG on ne comprend pas cet
échec he pourtant le développeur nous
avait habitué à des grands titres du jeu
vidéo comme Street Racing Syndicate
divers jeux de NASCAR ou encore big mer
truckers 2 avec son fameux slogan truck
me hardardeur mais voilà on ne veut pas
faire de généralité bien sûr même si là
en l'occurrence c'est très dur de pas
les faire et d'ailleurs anecdote ce
studio avait déjà failli couler une
première fois dans les années 90 mais
avait été sauvé de la faillite par
infogram le fameux French FLIR c'est bon
tu as fini fini quoi bah ton test parce
que là il est temps de
retourner sur la moto dépêche-toi ils
vont bientôt nous rattraper mais les
gars je suis à fond je peux pas aller
plus vite
[Musique]
tuentends
ça soyez moi
[Musique]
oh bah
merde oh merde droit
devant c'est pas un problème pour moi
[Musique]
mais comment tu fais ça en fait je suis
un ancien membre de is c'était en
1982 et attends mais tu étais pas né en
oui justement c'est parce
que oh merde
c'est qu'est-ce qu'on fait tu as un plan
ouais et on va avoir un
problème plus d'essence mais attends je
vais tenter un atterrissage en douceur
quelle
journée tu te rappellas on est
garé au moin avec tout ça on doit pas
très très loin des
locaux je crois que c'est foutu on va
être obligé de prendre le bus oh non mec
prendi dis pas ça jamais on prendra ce
[ __ ] de bus end e les gars vous voulez
que je vous
[Musique]
dépose et ben on a vécu des choses
aujourd'hui hein merci Maurice à la
prochaine salut bon allez bonne journée
les
gars
oh merde ah c'est la marche arrière bon
allez bonne
journée au revoir Mace
6 et ben voilà c'est parti tuas les clés
euh
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]